mais pendant ce temps l'armée
ukrainienne poursuit sa contre offensive
dans le sud de nombreux tirs
d'artillerie réseaux notamment autour de
la ville de carson on en parle avec vous
et armelle charrier bonjour armelle
l'ukraine et la russie parle
chacune de leur côté de réussite
concernant cette contre-offensive voulue
par l'armée ukrainienne qu'est ce qu'on
sait précisément de ce qu'il se passe en
ce moment alors on s'est en fait par la
communication qui en est fait et c'est
pour ça que c'est intéressant de
regarder des deux côtés quels sont les
narratif parce que dans une guerre quand
on est sur une opération qui se veut de
cette envergure là la communication
c'est aussi une influence et donc c'est
aussi une arme les russes pour l'instant
honte un discours qui est de dire que
ils savent canaliser l'opération qui est
en cours que ils ont détruit une partie
du matériel ukrainien que d'ailleurs ça
n'a pas là à l'importance que ça
expliqué par les ukrainiens et qu' il ya
aussi un nombre de soldats ukrainiens
qui sont touchés et qu'ils sont même
hospitalisé du côté d'odessa c'est dire
que du coup ils sont même déporté du
côté ukrainien la différence est tout
autre puisque on explique que cette
offensive a été mené en réflexion pour
couper justement les russes avec lediet
he le fleuve qui est en train de passer
que du coup ça permettrait de mettre
près de vingt mille soldats russes en
étau en fait qu'ils ne pourraient pas
ensuite regagné leur l'autre partie de
là des soldats russes ça c'est
intéressant parce que si c'est le cas
ramon donné on aura des prisonniers on
aura des images et puis que ils sont en
train de se battre effectivement sur une
ligne principalement du côté de carson
mais là galinier fait à peu près 100 km
si on la remonte il y a des deux côtés
des victoires et les défaites sur un
nombre de villages qui sont pris ou qui
ne sont pas pris voilà ce que l'on en
sait clairement pour l'instant ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on reste dans une
nébuleuse donc on a pas d'image tant
qu'on n'a pas effectivement de faits
fondamentaux qui sont annoncés en tout
cas les ukrainiens ont intérêt à
communiquer sur ce qui se passe alors
ils ont intérêt à la fois oui et la fois
de nom non militairement c'est là où
c'est surprenant c'est à dire que
lorsque l'on est sur une contre
offensive par définition à terme de
stratégie il faut qu'ils aient la
surprise donc on se tait en règle
générale sur ce qu'on est en train de
faire de telle sorte que l'ennemi
n'étant pas au courant et bien dans ces
cas-là on le surprend ensuite ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir clairement ce
qui va en ressortir de cette
communication la houle est importante
c'est que il faut d'une part pour les
ukrainiens mobiliser leurs opinions il
faut remonter le moral il faut expliquer
qu'on est capable de faire quelque chose
qu'on est capable de soutenir aussi de
cette ville de kherson où on a vu au
début du conflit qui avait quand même
ces chrétiens qui a agité le drapeau
même quand les russes étaient là ça
c'est un point important c'est aussi
important de légitimer l'action qui est
fait aujourd'hui par les occidentaux il
y as fourniture d'armement on ne sait
pas combien mais il y a fourni trois
mouvements il y a aussi une fourniture
pour former les ukrainiens y compris
avec des forces spéciales etc donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut montrer qu'il ya un
savoir faire dont khansa la
communication ukrainienne elle est
importante ensuite ce qui se passe sur
le terrain est ce qu'il ya aussi actions
effectivement des alliés sur place ça on
n'en sait rien et on ne sera
certainement pas avant longtemps merci
beaucoup et armelle pour c